[Music]
Super Bowl party got a plan you gonna
have a Super Bowl party yes no Super
Bowl party no Super Bowl party if you're
true football fan you do not go to Super
Bowl parties because it's all a bunch of
losers who don't watch it all year and
what they do is they talk during the
game and then they shut up during the
commercial and then the game comes back
like oh ho hum you think that one cost
no that's funny I thought that one's
Dunkin it's just like I just the rage
that goes through me through the game
and I just you know end up fighting you
know with somebody so what I do is I
tape the game I let it go like 90
minutes 90 minutes I shut off everything
and then I start watching that way I can
fast-forward through all of the crap all
of the fireworks the bands you don't
like you don't like the halftime show
no no and I love Bruno Mars but I'll go
to his concert I don't need to and they
keep talking about the weather like
that's gonna be the problem like like
it's gonna be for the bands they're
gonna add the hot that not to players
will be fine it's the band's they have
to sing in that weather flea never wears
a shirt those are the guys everybody
else it's gonna be fun yeah so you think
there's no problem there just so you
were just so opposed to them having a
party in the middle of the Superbowl
like you know having a happy I don't
like it's the most important game of the
year and they turn it into like this
this I don't know what it is I don't
know what it is anymore it used to be
like a little high school band came out
yeah
played a little song right and then that
was it and now they just carry shooting
t-shirts into the crowd I really sound
like a bumpy old man but I just want to
watch the game right I'm just gonna be
me sitting alone screaming at my TV
I like how it's one of those unavoidable
times to drink yeah oh yeah so you're
gonna be alone watching it on tape delay
bombed we don't say and run at all yeah
I'm actually I'm a happy drunk yeah
that's good